can you hear me
i hope this reaches you
this city is falling apart
chaos
madness
death
and there might be no going back
[Music]
but you can change that
it depends on the choice you make
truth
or lie
[Music]
but i don't have a choice
only you can do this
please
help me
finally we meet
son
the stage is set
the light shines brightest in the
darkest of times
all right i'm here for you don't worry
oh
protect
fulfill
[Music]
your destiny
hello charlie here with two of the
brilliant and twisted minds from neowiz
who created a game this reimagined
pinocchio as a
a ruthless killing machine to cleanse a
plague infested world made by the studio
behind beloved fantasy mmo bless
unleashed and coming from a team of
developers who worked on the absolutely
awesome monster hunter world i am super
excited about this one please welcome
juwon choi and jason park
i told you they were twisted it's lovely
to meet you whoever's underneath there
um
this is haunting truly haunting
should we have a look and see if we can
find the humans underneath yeah let's go
let's do it yeah i'm gonna do the slow
reveal
here they are
jason and juwon
[Laughter]
we have a joker
hello nice to meet you there they are
amazing they've joined us welcome now
when i think of pinocchio it doesn't
quite look uh up to the trailer that we
saw just now so could you let us know
where the idea of pinocchio is the
killing machine actually came from
our team is called off and this is the
first time we've developed a single
player console game so we need a way to
get our name out there
in order to stick in the minds of the
people our stretches was to choose our
subject that was very well known but
transform it into something completely
original
um we eventually choose the adventures
of the pinocchio but there wasn't a key
decision
we first thought about what pictures we
wanted our social life game to have of
the first
john ever referenced the taco fantasy or
medieval thing the second the story
shouldn't be chinese and we should be
able to enjoy it as it or dutch and last
the game should be full of adventures
and unforgettable characters
this is natural relatives to pinocchio
because it matches the conditions we
sell
i have a lot of pinocchio when i was
child but i was shocked when i leave
again more carefully recently the
adventures of the piano kill is
definitely not story for children but
rather like on our way to the movie for
adults
it was a real pleasure to take the
fantastic source of material and create
our own ordinary story tell really i bet
it is and now we're at gamescom showing
it off to the world yeah
so very proud of the initial idea of
making a game based on the story of
pinocchio
honestly i was not convinced at all
yeah
i was thinking that
pinocchio is a story for just for kids
that children for 90 or so like games
uh however even though i read the
pinocchio story long time ago
i i live in my family so i went to
bookstore bought a book and read it
again
and what i've learned is that
pinocchio is not just a character
it's more like a reflection of human
nature
and filled with a lot of
unique and attractive characters
that's when i realized
we need some
this is something we have to do
revitalizing this amazing story as a
game i think it sounds like i might need
a re-read of pinocchio then um but until
then do you want to give us a bit of a
deep dive of the story in the world the
pinocchio inhabits
as you already know elijah p is based on
the original story of pinocchio
which is actually quite a brutal
and while the main characters in elijah
p are for the pinocchio our game's story
is completely different and filled with
new events for example larger pe takes
place in the imaginary city of crotch on
where petrification disease is spreading
and causing a lot of conflict
and while you'll meet a lot of familiar
characters from the pinnacle
they want to be anything anything like
you remember
we chose the black lobby brotherhood
before
uh but i'd also like to tell you about
antonia who appears at the beginning of
the trailer
and the original story antonia is
actually antonio yeah japanese
that is or i can leave it today though
um
i will save the last for the future i
was going to say i definitely don't
remember these masks from my childhood
it's got to be said
yeah so me too
my favorite is black laby brotherhood
they're also in the original story
um you know poor black leavitt holding a
coffin on their shoulders
they're uh in leisure feet they are not
just arriving there are future warriors
they are still carrying a coffin and
always trying to speed you into you
i really want to see how you guys
survive when they hunting
so
in order to go up against them i have
seen from the trailer so far that there
are some ridiculous weapons and you can
even take some enemies to the wood shop
with them if i saw that correctly um so
talk us through the combat we can expect
from liza p and how similar is it to the
souls-like games we've been seeing
recently
um i can confidently say that lijo p is
full of unique and one-of-a-kind system
the first system i'd like to talk about
is the weapon combination shield weapons
are divided into two parts the blade and
the handle and can be combined in
countless ways each blade and the handle
have their own weight motions pictures
and special skills called forever art oh
okay so players are free to meet some
match and create the perfect weapon for
them
it should be fun to try out
more than hundreds of possible
combinations wow
and another unique system in elijah p is
the legion arm system which probably
already sounds on the main characters of
left arm yep yep yeah he has a
actual body of perfect yeah so it's
possible to modify it with the parts and
use special skills
they are particularly flesh and dynamic
and can also be strengthened
i'll be found to choose the right leg
amount for the situation
now i had a chance to play it earlier by
the way i'm just going to say and it is
so so difficult so i just want to let
anyone know out there that this game is
so difficult you are going to absolutely
love it but to answer the elephant in
the room obviously the original
pinocchio game and a big emphasis on his
nose growing with every single lie so i
have to ask does this element of the
pinocchio story play into lies of p at
all
yeah
first of all i think that uh lying is
the most important aspect of the
original story
and when you really think about it yeah
humans are capable of lying and there
can also be food for their humanity
this also means that we approach the
concept of lying in a completely
different way than the original
think about it is there any more than a
more human than using lies to achieve
something yeah we think that in order to
become real human one has to lie and
that is reflected in the game by players
experiencing a variety of events by line
the choices they make will also affect
the envelope
as for what this might do to his nose
i can support it for you
and you need to find it up for yourself
but i can guarantee you're not expecting
anything
i tell you what when the full game comes
out then the first thing i'm testing is
the lying yeah
in the game you can lie if you you'll be
a human
but always remembered like levi brothers
is always looking for a chance for all
liars into the coffin
right okay moving swiftly onwards from
that then um there had to be a ton of
people putting a lot of time into lysap
to uh pull the strings pun intended to
get a game like this off the ground so
can you talk about the development
process and were there any difficulties
actually getting people to buy into this
reimagining
actually in korea the majority of games
are online keys and mobile games
so there aren't many developers with
expertise in single players games for
consoles okay
so we did a lot of trial and error and
made a lot of mistakes but this was
unavoidable
despite
these challenging circumstances the fact
that our team not
had a lot of developers who already have
the experience with the console game
project was a major help yeah most of
all our team absolutely loves console
games so it was easy to get everyone on
board with our obedience for larger p
i would like to give all the credit to
our team members and
they are the reason why elijah p could
come this far yeah and i'm really really
proud of our team and i'm sure they are
so proud of you both sat here today
representing the game as well so shout
out to youtube yeah
yeah it is the first time for us to make
a single player game we all have a lot
of experiences on developing
action games but only limited to online
games
at first i was thinking that
making single player games would be
easier
uh in terms of technical perspective
like
the older toxic
issues etc
but it didn't take long that i realized
i underestimated
yeah our game needed a lot of pictures
we haven't
even imagined when you develop online
games okay we only have one playable
character which is which is easier to
make because online games normally have
more than five
very tricky but this one player
character i mean pinocchio
requires i guess you know
10 times more animation than the online
games makes sense yeah yeah pinocchio
uses a lot of different types of weapons
and
each weapon requires
total unique unique animation of
their color setup
so i had i have to admit i
our initial plan was
offer in terms of estimating the
the cost of the animations yeah
so if you look at our studio
and probably you can see our animated
artists and combat designers yelling
each other
and arguing all the time
we are still in this chaos but anyway we
are enjoying it and
definitely we'll be better at planning
the next time well i really appreciate
that you brought the chaos to us here in
germany but before we run out of time i
do want to give you to the floor to
share anything you want with everyone
out there about liza pease before its
release
actually
we didn't expect a large appeal to get
this much interest and
love from gamers we really really want
to thank you all for the tremendous
level of support
we do our absolute best and are sure
that you'll be mesmerized by the city of
city of cards
and take care and
see you in the
xbox game pass next year oh yeah
[Music]
yeah for everybody at gamescom don't
forget to visit our booth and play the
demo enjoy
and please share your experiences with
us
thank you for having us today and enjoy
gamescom with rise of tea
guys thanks again so much for joining me
but now dancing robots creepy